Donald Trump has been caught in not one
not two but three more lives easily
verifiable lies demonstrable lies and I
sort of say this casually because it
doesn't matter because the the people
who care about his lives already don't
support him and the people who don't
care about his lies aren't going to be
influenced by yet another lie so let's
go through lies one two and three number
one Donald Trump announced his
transgender military ban on Twitter last
week and he talked about consulting with
his generals in fact the first tweet was
after consultation with my generals and
military experts please be advised the
United States government will not accept
or allow transgender individuals to
serve in any capacity in the US military
we can skip the third part he talked
about his generals we had many questions
who did he consult did the generals
agree did they know this was coming were
they expecting it to be announced on
Twitter do they have an implementation
policy for this turns out the answer is
they weren't consulted asked for the
names of who was in consultation with
the White House Navy captain Jeff Davis
said he was not able to provide a single
name of who Donald Trump was referring
to in those tweets his generals that he
consulted with line number one line
number to remember Trump's disastrous
political speech to the Boy Scout
Jamboree it was he the last week or the
week before last here's 30 seconds of it
just to remind you about it you want to
achieve your dreams I said who the hell
wants to speak about politics when I'm
in front of the Boy Scouts
as the Scout law says hey scout is
trustworthy loyal we could use some more
loyalty I will tell you sure did
President Obama ever come to a Jamboree
do you remember that incredible night
with the maps and the Republicans are
red and the Democrats are blue and that
map was so red it was unbelievable after
the speech the Boy Scouts of America put
out a statement directed at Trump saying
hey we're nonpartisan we don't support
candidates blah blah blah clearly
distancing themselves from Trump and
also apologizing to anyone that was
offended by Trump's speech Donald Trump
told The Wall Street Journal that after
that ridiculous speech the head of the
Boy Scouts called him and told him it
was the greatest speech that was ever
made to them Time magazine went to the
Boy Scouts and said hey Trump says you
called him the Boy Scouts are unaware of
any call from any National Boy Scout
leadership to the White House verifiable
lies that is line number two and now
this is a great one why number three
Donald Trump claimed that the Mexican
president recently called to commend him
on the great job he is doing with
immigration Mexico denies that that call
took place and that the Mexican
president called Trump specifically to
say you're doing a great job on
immigration can I propose something
Trump said he consulted with my generals
is it possible we all assumed when he
said my generals he meant American
generals and maybe he met generals from
a different country like maybe when it
come says my generals he's talking about
Russian generals or some other military
I don't know it was in the morning so
maybe he was having some General Mills
cereal at the time General Mills he
consulted with General Mills yeah this
is lying of a path that's pretty good
that I like that one this is lying of a
pathological nature and he kicked off
his presidency with I had the largest
inauguration attendance ever so my only
question is why did his staff why do his
staff allow him to keep doing interviews
is it because the people around him
think it's a good idea which means
they're incompetent or is it because
they can't control Trump which is
trouble for Donald Trump probably a
combination of the two right a
combination of power
this incompetent yes people surrounding
the president I have to admit I'm a
little bit desensitized to all these
lives but it does draw my attention when
there's lies on top of lies
yeah so for example the Don jr. story
that came out yesterday that he was
involved in the initial response right
that response to was also a lie yeah the
dollars of multiple layers its life
section right so the response from Trump
jr. contained lies and the White House
lied that Trump's senior wasn't involved
in crafting Trump juniors lie but he was
why not just tell the truth
I know if you're not doing anything
wrong just tell the truth today's
program is made possible in part by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at game fly offer comm slash TDPS
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30-day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDPS